bio oder was geht ab und herzlich kommen
zu einer runde
okay das war nicht so cool wie ich mir
gerade vorgestellt habe wurde das so
richtig gut machen aber das dauert ein
bisschen länger als es angezeigt wird
eigentlich verschwindet es ist mein
block langsam
diese bekommen natürlich spaß wir
spielen geld auch mal wieder
ich habe es gar nicht geschaut was für
karten genau daran kommen aber ich hoffe
mal dass wir einigermaßen was reißen
können wobei es natürlich mittlerweile
mehr leute get down spiel und da könnte
es natürlich problematisch werden ja ich
komme gerade von der bahn und das ist
ein gefährliches gute überleitung aller
zeiten
wie ihr wisst ja ich habe letztens und
videoüberwacht mit der deutschen bahn zu
den sportcamps und das kann richtig gut
bei euch an
auf jeden fall gefreut dass ihr ja dass
hier wird für sowas auch offen sein
und heute haben mich meine guten
kollegen von der deutschen bahn noch mal
angehauen ob ich nicht über das thema
job berufswahl sonst was mit ihr
quatschen will und deshalb dachte ich
mir
erzähle ich einfach mal so ein bisschen
was wie das bei mir aussieht was ich
immer machen wollte was immer werden
wollte was ich jetzt werden will
und ja also bei mir so ich hatte halt
diese typischen kindheitswunsch polizei
sonst was glaube ich wollte nicht
astronaut werden nicht irgendwas
ausgefallen aber ich wollte immer
polizist werden
das hat sich also mittlerweile besser
sind natürlich nicht mehr so es gibt
bestimmt leute die bisschen von anfang
an als kind was irgendwann mal sein
wollen aber bei mir war das nicht der
fall
und ja im moment ist eigentlich so
lecker
im moment ist es so ich habe viel spaß
an youtube und medienproduktion
unterhaltung sonstwas dass sich
höchstwahrscheinlich was in dieser
richtung machen werde
ich hatte letztens auch schon mal ein
video angeschnitten darf man da kommt
auch noch was auf euch zu und das ist
jetzt falls sich jemand an verändert
dieses video
okay ich habe einen körper lag ein
bisschen auf jeden fall gibt es
natürlich viele leute die nicht wissen
so gerade mit g8 jetzt was man was man
machen sollte und nach dem abitur nach
der quali mittlere reife sonstwas und
die deutsche bahn
deshalb haben sie mich überhaupt an
gehauen haben etwas im angebot soll ich
mal dass wenn sie einen job provider
also der deutsche bahn job profiler und
das ist ein
ein text sozusagen beziehungsweise ein
profiler mit dem man herausfinden kann
was für jobs school für einen sind und
ich bin ja ein relativ cool also man
kann einfach herausfinden was was kannst
du machen was passt zu dir anhand von
einigen angaben die man da macht man
sagt zum beispiel wo seine stärken
liegen teamfähigkeit und so weiter und
so fort
und dass wir nicht ziemlich cool und
deshalb dachte ich mir klar freunde wenn
ich am start
ich werde euch glaube ich auch mal als
ich glaube ich selbst mal einen test
machen dort und werde dann irgendwie das
ergebnis in den die beschreibung packen
oder so da irgendwo irgendwie verstecken
und vielleicht findet ihr dann und ihr
könnt es natürlich gleichermaßen auch
machen einfach link ist ganz oben in der
beschreibung könnte es einmal aus tekken
und schauen was für euch raus kommt das
würde mich auch interessieren lesbar
geht es richtig gut 770 gebäudetrakt
f-cell selbstlos irgendwie hört sich
immer so okay aber er ist ja noch ein
paar punkte holen dann kommt natürlich
mich jetzt einfach mal mehr auf das
spiel und
weniger ausreden ich hoffe das ist okay
für euch das kommt dann dabei aus wenn
ich mich mehr aufs spiel konzentrieren
da unten sind einige blöcke hab ich ihn
wenigstens auch noch unter ich weiß es
nicht genau
na ja es könnte schwierig werden jetzt
im finale was zu reißen der andere typ
hat fast 500 points mehr als ich weiß
irgendwie nicht so super super effektiv
aber es war kein keine lüge gerade ich
komme wirklich direkt von der bahn
die überleitung ich komme gebiet direkt
von der bahn
und deshalb denke ich nicht eingespielt
oder sonstwas weil dieser zum tage weg
war und wollen wir mal sehen was wir
machen können was nicht interessieren
würde es wird kommt ob das rauskommt was
ich mir für mich selbst vorstellen
also ich würde ja behaupten die
eigentlichen spiel konzentrieren aber
ich würde behaupten dass ich für mich
selbst schon relativ genau weiß was ich
machen will
aber ob das auch bei mir herauskommt ich
weiß das nicht vielleicht gibt es ja
andere sachen die laut dem profil besser
zu mir passen aber dieser lässt reggae
typ war richtig gut 15 hat der krasse
leute wenn wir das machen können dann
bin ich echt stolz auf mich
ok meine altbekannte ich probiere alles
ins enchantment zu stecken taktik und 13
ich weiß nicht ob ich weiter gehen soll
und vielleicht noch bei aspect aufträge
da kann es natürlich sein dass schaden
muss runter geht aber ich glaub ich
mache einfach risiko ich habe 13 immer
noch wenn jetzt noch mal drauf gekriegt
vielleicht noch feier aspect mal
gedrückt und schreibe 13 immer noch ich
glaube ich das gut sein leute vielleicht
vielleicht hätte ich noch mal ein ich
weiß es noch nicht aber ich mache
wirklich komplett auf offensive und
geben nur wirklich nur auf angriff ok
ich muss jetzt einfach machen
14 herzen plus gott ich muss mir irgend
jemanden rauspicken
ich will euch braucht nerven oder 13
immer noch okay es war kein problem es
war kein problem bieten zufrieden ist
schlimmste wäre einfach gewesen wenn ich
jetzt irgendwie schaffen uns einst nur
noch gehabt hätte
und schon herz verloren das war nicht so
schlau und es ist ein guter typ ich weiß
nicht der steckt jetzt voll viele ein
soll im vergleich zu mir ich muss
wirklich klug kämpfer aber ich glaube
das ist ein guter erster typ den ich
angreifen kann
mit der glaube ich nicht so richtig
viele gute sachen
okay das natürlich der pz
ok ich sehr gut der da vorne hat nur
lieder rüstung das heißt zehn
höchstwahrscheinlich vorknöpfen und sehr
gut hat mich nicht einmal getroffen
schluss ehrte selbst auch gold äpfel
vielleicht können mit denen jetzt auch
noch holen
ich mache wahrscheinlich relativ gut
schaden sehr gut sehr gut jetzt bin ich
schon mal auf reisen rüstungen freunde
das ist nämlich die ich stecke alles in
offensive taktik die kann gut gehen wie
es gerade zu funktionieren scheint aber
man kann halt auch voll runtergehen und
ja ich hoffe mal dass ägypten verletzt
ich hoffe mal dass das passt
einigermaßen aber er hat extrem gut
range dem es uns vorwerfen oder so aber
kann man schon nicht sagen also
freundchen ich habe 5 aber ich hab' ich
hab mich schon gut hochgekämpft 23
herzen als ob der typ ist ja nur noch
krank weiß nicht ob ich denn jemals und
wenn ja wie ich den hund so hätte sie
gar im bewegt sondern plötzlich stand
der form obwohl es nicht mein weg war
ich glaube ich habe einfach mal
überraschen dabei ist es dumm das ist
gerade so ein bisschen liegt und wir
sind auch nur noch vier leute
okay das ist ne
series
was soll das ich bin traurig dein ernst
wie verstehe ich nicht naja ok deutsche
ich hoffe mal deshalb leicht gefallen
dieses wunderschöne ende aber ich fand's
eigentlich echt interessant ich meine
klar es war so das war eine kampagne und
so weiter und so fort aber die themen
finde ich wirklich wirklich interessant
und checken link aus ganz unten unten
ganz oben in der beschreibung und ja ich
komme jetzt erstmal klar was gut lief